nadège bonjour alors quel est l'état
d'esprit des participants à cette marche
pour écouter amira vous vous en doutez
beaucoup d'émotion et 6,1 alors de cette
marche blanche qui poursuit son cours on
a quitté la place de l'uruguay il y a un
peu plus du moins peu moins d'une heure
maintenant beaucoup d'émotion avec les
prochains de l'assedic souvient shui
bian en première ligne de cette marche
blanche alors on peut apercevoir doria
chou via et donc la veuve de cédric
souvient et plusieurs personnalités
politiques notamment de la france en
soumises eric coquerel
on a aperçu beaucoup de monde on a
aperçu également esther benbassa le
député écologiste aller vers le
journaliste réalisateur david dufresne
l'avocat de la famille également arié
alimi
voilà beaucoup d'émotion pour rendre
hommage à cédric show via qui a perdu la
gym ya un an jour pour jour lors d'une
interpellation policière qui a donc
dégénéré un puisqu'il s'est retrouvé un
savon à le plaquer au sol avec son
casque sur la tête il a fait l'objet
d'une clé d'étranglement qui lui a
fracturé sur la rixe avec nous le père
de cédric joue bien donc christian
chevandier à merci d'être avec nous
pourquoi c'était important d'organiser
cette marche blanche
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que ça fait
aujourd'hui un an pile que chez brick
est décédé il est tombé dans un
guet-apens
pour moi aujourd'hui après réflexion
c'est un guet-apens
il a été étranglé étranglé avec une
fracture du larynx
il n'y a pas laissé de chance de survie
on l'a laissé sur le trottoir pendant
plus de trois minutes
chants et auteur d'un plaquage vantera
les comblements est aujourd'hui en
justice est elle si son cours elle
travaille bien mais pas pour ceux qui
travaillent pas assez
le ministère de
ministère de la police qui fait rien il
veut pas les mettre à pied et ça ça nous
révolte c'est une révolte parce que ça
fait un an qu'ils sont toujours en
exergue un exercice ils font rien et il
se passe ce qui se passe qui sait pas ce
qu aujourd'hui c'est une injustice
voilà ni on en ferait la famille est en
colère
heureusement on est une famille soudée
excusez moi on est une famille très
soudée on ne veut pas de haine on ne
veut pas de deux bagarres nous ce qu'on
veut c'est la justice est aujourd'hui la
police la préfecture
darman on ne fait pas ce qu'il faut là
la mort l'allemand fait des mensonges
il a il a menti sur toute la longueur il
a depuis le début c'est un tissu de
mensonges et aujourd'hui s'avère que
dans les quatre policiers
il y en a deux qui ont déjà une
infraction pour déjà on les avait sans
liberté et la preuve c'est que ils ont
tué mon fils derrière et ils auraient dû
être suspendus ils ont pas été suspendu
michael perez est un assassin leur a
joué à la toute fin pour exciter elle
est juste témoin
assister à quatre la policière oui oui
la palestine a révélé qu'en allant
témoin assisté et et comment il s'avère
que elle devrait devrait être inculpé
comme les autres elle n'y est pas et ça
c'est un scandale c'est un scandale
c'est amer face à ça va faire comment
ces mamans fait vous ressentez à mon
sens la c6 à l'assassinât parce que il
ya dès qu il ya un des quatre policiers
qu'à un moment elle a dit bon c'est bon
faut arrêter et il a continué donc il
n'a pas entendu il y michael p résident
est à avoir des problèmes c'est quand il
est aveugle il est aveugle il est sourd
c'est vrai qu'il est noir sur le pavé il
dit qu'il n'a pas entendu il n'a pas vu
noir alors qu'il est en train de le tuer
donc c'est un menteur c'est un assassin
et le je pèse mes mots et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la justice serait qu' il
soit une mise à pied déjà tous les
quatre dès qu'on est en justice on va y
arriver en justice mais parce qu'elles
travaillent bien la justice aujourd'hui
on a des juges qui sont qui veulent la
vérité
ils veulent pas défendre la police s'ils
veulent la vérité la vérité et il se
passe que c'est cédric aujourd'hui il ya
cinq orphelins
il ya une veuve il ya une mère tu es
déchiré il ya un père qui est déchiré
moi je suis déchiré au plus profond de
moi même ma fille avait déchiré
elle est au plus mal au plus bas moi je
pleure tous les jours mon fils tous les
jours je verse une larme
parce que c'est c'est scandaleux ce qui
se passe ces scandales 1
et darmanin il veut faire passer les
nouvelles lois pour comme quoi on a pu
leur faire le film ci avait pas de film
ou si elles payent vidéo
s'il n'y avait pas eu comment de témoins
on n'aurait rien ça sera un délinquant
cédric alors que c'est pas un
travailleur il partait faire sa tournée
et sur un contrôle inopiné inopinés 1
contre le pays dont on ya mixité sa
plaque idée ça la première ici était au
téléphone c'était pas vrai puisque il
avait enterré fin de prêt décroché que
le casque donc il n'a pas besoin de ça
et là aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
tout ça c'est un tissu de mensonges que
la police le gouvernement
l'allemand l'allemand a couvert ont
couvert le préfet de police de paris à
couvert moi j'ai pas de respect pour ces
gens là parce qu'ils ont peu de respect
pour la mort de mon fils
donc j'ai aucun respect à avoir envers
eux et puis c'est des assassins et il
couvre les assassins donc aujourd'hui on
est dans un scandale un scandale mais je
pense que la sphère cédric ça va être
une grosse affaire et qui rend gros
dénouement j'espère que choisit le
dernier sport qui reste celle à la
justice trois et quatre policiers ont
été mises en examen
quelque chose quand même y en a trois
pour été mis en examen et lyonnais qui a
été mis en témoin assisté voilà enfin
c'est quand même scandaleux quand on
voit les propos qu'elle a eues on a bien
droit de rigoler on avait le droit de
s'amuser c'est quand même honteux de
voir ça
c'est c'est scandaleux comment on peut
dire on a bien le droit de s'amuser
alors que le guen en train de crever par
terre enfin je comprends pas je
comprends pas que darmanin il veut pas
se réveiller et veut pas dire alors dans
la sphère de michel leydier guerre le
producteur il a il a mis deux de deux
personnes en prison pour passer les
fêtes parce que ça ya fait un petit coup
de main un petit coup de pub
un jour ils ont fait vingt jours d'arrêt
merci merci cédric oesch souviens de nos
bagues tambadou excusez moi merci en
tout cas nous avoir accordé ce
témoignage
merci à vous tous merci à vous tous et
on est contentes la presse voilà que les
journalistes puissent faire leur travail
et que voilà on est content tout ça et
on est vraiment fiers de la france quand
on voit qu on a une presque et kéké qui
est au devant de tous les événements
beaucoup remercie donc vous l'avez
entendu amira christian show via donc
qui est bien est toujours aussi en
colère après la mort de son fils
un an après la mort de son fils vous
l'avez entendu beaucoup d'émotion
également d'en savoir ce qu'ils
réclament c'est donc la suspension de
ces quatre policiers qui sont dans les
jours aujourd'hui en exercice décision
incompréhensible selon lui merci à des
agents pour toutes ces précisions